praise the old gods and the new
because Game of Thrones is coming back
but before we embark into season seven
I'm here to catch you up on all the
iciest twists and Wildfire iasts
turns
[Music]
previously in Westeros a sinner comes
before you Cersei of House Lannister
hell hath no fury like a Lannister
scorned determined to get revenge for
her humiliating walk of atonement shame
and regain control of the kingdom
Cersei devised a plan to kill two birds
with one stone and by birds we mean the
sparrows and by stone we mean a massive
explosion of wildfire poor Queen
Margaery was among these thousands who
were instantaneously murdered and little
King Tommen was so incredibly
heartbroken by this loss that he calmly
relinquished his ground walked over and
took a tumble out of his bedroom window
by Tommen Cersei took her place on the
iron throne as the new queen of the
Seven Kingdoms
elsewhere Arya Stark urged her eyesight
back buddy then should we realize that
the life of a faceless assassin just
wasn't for her so she reunited with
needle left the city of Braavos and
finally crossed off one of these biggest
memes from her hit list sorry not sorry
Walder Frey
and speaking of gruesome deaths our
beloved Hodor sacrificed himself in
order to save brand from an army of
vicious White Walkers and we finally
discovered that Hodor was actually short
for something as for a Denarius well
following her dramatic dragon escape
from marine our Khaleesi was captured by
the hot-headed Dothraki men and was
sentenced to live out the rest of her
life among the other widows of the calls
the Doge killeen yeah right in one of
the most heated moments of the season
Dany set a fiery trap killing all the
calls and she emerged victorious and
invert as the new leader of the Dothraki
now once back in marine Danny consulted
with Tyrion the newly appointed hand of
the Queen and unleashed a dragon filled
plan to finally end slavery in slavers
Bay once and for all with the help of
the Greyjoy's of finest ships the
Dothraki Army and unsullied soldiers are
finally enroute to Westeros and our
mother of dragons has her eyes on the
Iron Throne
as for the north well after the red
woman brought our Lord Commander back to
life we finally got to witness a stark
family reunion
my stark loving heart can't take this
right now well Sasa and john teamed up
to take back Winterfell from the
ruthless Ramsay Bolton and they traveled
all over the north requesting soldiers
to join their fight how small Montes
kept face with house stop four thousand
years you will not break faith today
that's right it was the Battle of the
bastards and right before John's
itty-bitty army charged Ramsey aimed for
one last stark family casualty poor Rick
on you should have been so useless truly
though like no one's gonna miss Rick on
sorry I forgot about you a long time ago
with the surprise help from the Knights
of the Vale
John defeated the Bolton's took back
Winterfell and Sansa got some
much-needed Ramsay revenge now John is
king of the north but thanks to brands
working we finally discovered the real
secret between Jon Snow's mysterious
heritage turns out he's actually not a
[ __ ] Stark's bastard son his mom is
actually Ned's sister Lyanna really
close and we're to believe that John's
father is Rhaegar Targaryen which
according to tradition that puts him
first in the line of succession for the
Iron Throne plus that also means that
Danny is technically ready for this
Jon's aunt insane right I kind of love
it
but the real war between the dead and
the living is still coming because after
six seasons of ominous warnings winter
is here the enemy is real
oh okay did you guys get all that good
because now my brain is dark and full of
terrors
but make sure you keep it locked to et
online all season for exclusive Game of
Thrones news and check in ETS YouTube
page each and every Monday for the
ultimate after-show Westeros weekly
thanks so much for stopping by guys I'll
see you next time
[Music]
you